[Music]
[Applause]
this is the technical difficulties with
playing citation needed joining me today
he reads books you know it's Chris Joel
follow me on twitter at toast at now
it's part
everybody's favorite Gary Brannen Gary
Brannen pulldown events and only outs in
an English country I'm gonna have to get
the bleep out in the first minute
thought I make it easy for you and the
bounciest man on stage Matt gray well I
we can do visual gags
[Music]
like Bob Dylan before he went electric
in front of me I've got an article from
Wikipedia and these folks can't see it
every fact get right to the point and
they ding and a special prize for
particulars which is oh yeah oh yeah and
today we are talking about Ruth
Belleville Belleville Belleville a town
of bells I mean I don't imagine that see
etymology oh well you never know do know
is that a town of Ruth bells Oh Ruth
Belleville right okay sorry
give me a second oh no to name two words
one name is it a person or a place
it is deafness because it's a
person-to-person is you're a woman yes
[Music]
the first point of the day is anyone
keeping track of the point a because I'm
not well we never do okay do you want to
kind of guess when about we're talking
the Victorian era when we play on this
bill at the time of big hats and iron
does she have any ayah
careful answer she has some silver used
to be gold it's now silver so she has no
iron she's not massively anemic if
that's what you say
that's why oh you know me time right now
that I'm the enemy a gag did have a
trouser press she is famous for having a
physical object oh great so you got a
woman who has a thing a human the thing
with silver that was billed only was it
a goblet I'm sorry was it a what was it
a goblet no that's not the gesture for
gobbler
[Music]
one can come back up yes we found the
audience's level and it's down there is
something that would come in silver and
gold would have a silver or gold case
was this a jeweler what point hey yeah
that's right ah absolutely
I had this feared Elizabeth Ruth Naomi
Belleville 1854 to 1943 and known for
carrying around a watch okay with she
I'm going to go something an sorry Syd
something to do with trains and time
zones huh always I mean give it's a
watch it's to do with time the coin on
steering is long oh you know what it is
not quite it's close official keeper of
the Queen's o'clock we're getting closer
corgis time Greenwich Mean Time
certainly has something to do with it
cool I've just realized you have 37
minutes off the hour CST excuse me ma'am
I just need to take the corns oh yes
it's tight
set my watch to Corgi I tell you what it
is basically like 37 minutes it is still
in the parlor at Buckingham Palace so
Mary's pulling out the elaborate silver
dish right now used to be gold you know
it does tarnish so why would someone in
Victorian London and later up to World
War World War two be going around with a
wok machine official clock setter for
some town or borough I'll give you a
point for that certainly doesn't
official this would be unofficial that
going around second to our own bloody
time she's a guerrilla talking setter
you can't set time on a good video
they don't wear watches like a Banksy
haha you thought it was five minutes
later than it is yeah but would I know
it's wrong cuz I have a watch ah now
tell about the point if the gorilla told
you the time you wouldn't disagree with
that would you whatever time he says it
is I will point out you're getting very
close there this is this is how no no
Gary isn't Matty's massive this is
someone who went round selling oh oh you
don't
III know the time give me a fiver and
I'll tell you the time kind of person
yeah oh my god absolutely right spot on
shake you can do that in Leicester
Square I mean you wouldn't want to in
Parliament squats you got Big Ben there
but let's just it's 11:55 dawn trust me
that's wrong that's not actually Big Ben
that is just Gary going dog
which bit of me remains opens everything
if you do go to Parliament Square on a
Thursday night you can just see him
standing in the corner doing impression
of big banks yeah I even put the pointy
hat on and everything and for some tour
it is a very small faraway thing it does
work as well
yeah how BIG's the pendulum Gareth you
don't want to try I'll tell you is just
regulated by a penny every year that's
doing it that they regulate the pendulum
on the clock and Big Bear putting
pennies on or subtracting it to half a
second or something like that
Oh penny well with the exchange rate at
the moment it's good who pounds
such a mountainous did the brexit one
Hey yep oh this was a woman are called
Ruth Belvin who Belleville who like how
father and her father before her her
father and his father get a diagram her
Jenner is always difficult arm
generations you need the word generation
for generations
had sold the time to people who needed
to know it accurately so where did she
go to get Time magazine
it's a grudging biscuits but it's a
biscuit
I will not put in scales of biscuit Rhea
so where did she go to get the proper
time in Victorian London this was this
was originally 1836 when her father
created it the london time dump now
that's a good description for what this
would be oh great I win them they're not
giving you a point for it but we're in
that my short arms would where would you
go to get the time a Greenwich had in it
yes absolutely right Greenwich
Observatory you see the nonchalance on
that yeah run jobs over you would go
you've got the clock but he's outside
surely you go to its herb garden Oh
[Music]
the browser that got the reaction is
purely user because our despair of 400
make even in front that is what my
Panzer were that's button and they are
back in the pavilion shaking her head
yes there is there is a lot outside
called the Shepherd gate clock what's
unusual about it's got sheep on it no
hands on it shepherds only can go under
it no to all of the heavens are you sure
I mean it's set on a wall so if anyone
can get under it I'll be very surprised
is it on a Viking street named Sheppard
Street ah no it's by the Shepherd gate
of the observer a sheep work like
sundials don't look they all face the
same way
yeah it almost many fine saxon church is
what you find engraved on it is four
holes with a hook the who's in Brushy
it's 20 past Flossie then they fall off
you get any when you get a goat cause
all cause of problems now go
that's me recalibrate with a penny on
their back every few hours together
within a few seconds so I was wrong
yes you are it is a fairly standard
clock there is something unusual about
it particularly for that arrow that you
would you would need to tell the time
day night anything 24 hour 24 hour by
watch absolutely right 24 hour clock so
you would go there well she would go
there would set her watch exactly and
then go around well hundreds of clients
slide in someone under cutter and just
charge slightly less with a different
watch ah I'm there you have stumbled
upon something so I'll give you a point
Oh looky she came under attack from San
John win a director of the Standard Time
company Standard Time 20 bus three get
out okay um what kind of criticism did
did he give in a speech at the United
Ward's Club oh I will not take time from
a woman I'm not a place for her
something I really think like that once
enough he said he yeah she might have
been using her femininity half a minute
reinventing leaning to gain business oh
I see but what about my channel um the
speech was published in The Times
with both of you doing that impression
because I got a very vivid imagination
it's got you in local Victorian dresses
hanging around a pub in the East End and
really I can't sleep before
where are my hands still doing this
someone but uh so yes but following the
publication of the comments what
happened she got really pissed off and
threw her watching him but he was on a
chain so she could keep doing it's like
like a yo-yo to my drunken I hope you
had a bell in it every time the hit was
like I so know if what time's it I've
got no idea
oh you want to know what time it is it's
whooping died uh quite the opposite
actually
yawning she took it in good humor uh she
did uh it resulted in increase in sales
and what what did she say about his
comment a little bit little a few more
words and I don't don't
uh he just given her free advertising
that nails love that yeah excuse me miss
I hear you provide services of time I'd
like to buy some of your time 2:30 there
you go that wasn't quite what I had in
mind but my watch is actually says oh I
can't say I lost from this transaction
um yes
she uh she lived to the age of 89 and
she'd know that cookie um she uh what
what did how long she have before that
for her retirement nah nah
did you just keep going to she chill
chichi car clogged spur a little bit 12
minutes exactly i watch on the body
until her that come on man great I said
look but really this is about it because
everybody roll up your sleeves this
one's coming did she meet her and timely
death
[Applause]
that was better I was gonna say it don't
you like the third stroke no but she got
three years of retirement
well noting for is blitzing I started
the Blitz oh she's walking through
blitzed on London's and telling the
Nazis to F off all she's walking on with
a clock you know run hero each T time
they'll be bombing in 15 minutes
how did she know that there is a remnant
out there there is a reference to a
bogey in here as well so imagine there
was there was something else you may
have been achieving choosing a good car
nine like victorian-era so long Gary
it's an iron scooter Oh designed by
Brunel himself and then first reference
to drew now if you've got your bingo
cards that must be lying
says the man in a bobs full house hoodie
precisely one person in the audience
thank you for that just exactly the
woman 400 people this is aim to appeal
to as I'm I let's face it so when she
retired after after the generations of
doing this and it was clear that this
was not necessary anymore because the
standard time company while they did not
win themselves that technology moved on
what was the standard time companies
selling substandard shoddy time not
collected fresh from Greenwich every
morning just send them yesterday's time
it'll be fine it's only slightly stale
big buckets of time line down by the
gates filling it from the hand pop of
chronology there you go we've got some
time back in the Devonian yeah i melted
your bean dispense sounds like Gary
that's how you imagine most noises fair
cop actually well we might as well while
we're doing bingo and Gary noises goofs
huh goose on a train uh-huh goose being
hit by a train uh-huh
[Music]
what they're waiting for Gary that's why
you asked me Ana um what was the
standard time company selling how did
they get their time to people I realized
I'm treating times a physical thing here
how do they tell other people the time
telephoning or telegram or telic
communicating in some kind of way on a
wire that's a wood wood Telegraph mas
code sex message Skype Gary gets the
point it was a telegraphic time signal
service Brown giving Matt a point as
well she was so close he got the idea
you got the word in mill towns in took
North where we come from they go round
with a manifestly a man with no great
big stick would just whack on the window
to wake you up and that was the knocker
up because he was the unlimited watch
yeah he was the knocker oh yeah lots of
kids that look suspiciously similar you
know yes the standard time company sold
a telegraphic time signal but by that
point we had radio we had another free
time and the customers were was starting
to to die out essential did you have the
Speaking Clock by then as well 1936 oh
yeah it exists there is one other signal
at the Royal observe in Greenwich
obviously she went up got it from the
clock on the official source what
happens every day at the Royal
Observatory on the top of the hill
someone gets their fingers trapped in it
or any yells on the hour no one's ever
got around to fixing it I'll just get
the milk ah Jesus works I say level
where did that come from
where does it all come from Tom I don't
know no 1 1 p.m. at the top of the hill
in Greenwich Park a thing happens sorry
ups the balls right
do you want to explain that first there
yet does the time ball isn't that hot
see this one of things that sounds
rubbish but actually actually isn't
thank you that's that's actually a good
mind that's a lard time himself there do
you want to explain the time please
explain can't understand the time ball
it's a bottom bar on a stick that drops
down at one o'clock is it something like
so ships on the River Thames could
synchronize their kilometers before they
set off on a sale so they knew it was
one o'clock a bit like the one o'clock
good in Edinburgh where they're fair a
big I've gone at the top of the castle
to scare all the turrets because that's
what he's gone I was once a head of a
castle hold on hold on thank you carry
on as a third one needed and I was once
I had Andrew Castle on holiday looking
down through the telescope as the 1aqaq
good went off you see them bastards duck
down if you're ever in Vienna they test
that means going to me um they test the
air raid sirens in the city once a month
still Oh which I imagine is just to
annoy tourists now yeah but it's the
three-minute warning the bombs about to
drop
I want a helmet and to be able to run
whyever both those things unachievable
congratulations Chris you in this world
you went a gambling den for nocturnal
birds of prey run by the star of The
Godfather from the back of a 59 Chevy oh
Jesus Christ
someone just got that it's Al Pacino's
El Camino our casino ah with that we say
thank you to Chris Joel Gary Brannen
macro we will see you in 10 minutes
after the interval
[Music]
you